hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master hurry not our with black we
don't have a name a thinker no name
let's see what do we get some we may
nine ok now this line i recently saw
that Bishop h5 supposed to be
interesting here but i don't know that
not really it can get to the same kind
of position that we get now just post a
little bit more precise I saw that in
the latest book by which Victor Borge on
but couldn't really i didn't study at
yet in detail hmm since he takes 25 the
most normal move over here probably got
distracted by something not kind of more
you invest time I think this is okay
97's also move
how that's an interesting north tryon 45
hmm a problem is aged six if he goes h3
probably have to take on f3 and that's
not exactly what I want to do hmm I'm
also wondering is see if c4 is a move
but that isn't it doesn't feel right
yeah I probably have to take them on
right f 8 9 f8 looks quite safe yeah
maybe do that and have a possible but
should be six now as well so that age
three I can keep a bishop interesting
okay I'm taking this this is going for
some 94 here or 94 I think bishop at
three it makes lots of sense age 3 I
also can't go bishop age five it doesn't
seem to mind that it off interest very
interesting okay so if i take this when
it doesn't threaten on c8 i can push c4
for example answer interesting move ok
let's go for that tell your shower
position here
Wow I don't really have no idea what's
going on here okay let's play this for
c3 and if he takes Knight eggs that
looks fairly active and it takes a look
I don't I don't think that this is such
a big deal Bishop on g6 will be very
strong and I have 96 and so on we'll see
maybe look the one first team to provoke
Quincy seven and then 96 those kind of
things can also be interesting that's
very very tough very tough to figure out
this pollution
I can actually take with the rook Knight
takes looks white not sure no you're not
sure you have to sometimes just go by
instinct here maybe you can take
playbook see one that that looks
dangerous mm-hmm now that doesn't look
good hmm that's not good at all yeah I
have to
I have to go Queenie six or something
like that after Luke see one came doing
there I have 9 a-3 as well
each wife is also very tough sorry been
a long day long day of much talking so
where is this a kind of under stress age
fives debatable move for sure one thing
is there the exchanges is really not
relevant here
look see 1i have queen is six I really
don't see anything better but I think I
can teach you for maybe 92 I will
capture hmm ok at the move I did not
think about it all so if i take here
what is the point ok i'm taking yeah but
he cannot take CA that's Knight f3 so
okay I think I'm taking him and night is
sick so that should be quite nice
we can take the 40 in G for check that
looks pretty much decisive the he cannot
check I couldn't couldn't do anything
anymore here Knight f3 wins the house
jack white resign yeah it was very tough
game very tough game ever you have no
idea what was going on my exchange
sacrificing not sure process was an
interesting interesting try at least
yeah around here I'm I'm out of out of
book always feel that these positions
are I'm very very complicated we have
all the pieces still on the board and
many there are many conflicts let's aim
yeah the computer likes why it here but
not much it wants to take play a form
now give 0.3 nothing special but not at
a particularly yeah deep calculation
depth okay take stakes I'd also looked
quite normal this okay 96 was the what's
the normal movement c4 is interesting at
the engine likes this the question is
before here if this is something the
engine just wants to play night is six
and gives gives me a big advantage yeah
that looks that looked very normal that
move but i was still fascinated by that
before idea as I'm threatening c3 it
pretty much it almost forces seem to
take on c8 and get all this snow he
wants to take with the rook the compute
of it okay this kind of position I felt
like this could be compensation but of
course I couldn't be sure it's it's very
difficult
my bishop is pretty strong and the night
looks active the computer wants to play
Quincy one that looks very logical this
this it doesn't like Queen see one makes
an awful lot of sense putting up that
pin yeah I had this feeling that rook
see one might might come dear queen is
six is good for black hair no that's a
very awkward pin and look see one is is
kind of putting the Queen I mean how to
unpin so I understand this more but
Quincy one seems to be better for wine I
can I t6 is the computer move I mean I
have some compensation but it's it's it
doesn't seem to be enough this is what
the engine is giving these kind of ideas
sometimes I mean like taking Roxie three
this is kind of them yeah it looks fishy
it the tribute that gives plus one for
wide so that idea was probably not good
objectively but after Bishop t4 here h5
I am clearly better am so it is it is
it's tough to play it's really tough to
play you can see one and yes I can take
now yeah Tim thank ya I'm winning Queen
g4 is such a huge threat and I mean I
material up now at the moment two points
for the exchange plus plus this position
he is losing everything check Jim just
just taking things and I have got three
points or something already yeah it was
a very very sharp and unclear kind of
game with with white making the mistakes
here with Bishop defying us yeah I
probably should have heard
plate them simple 96 in my head looks
very okay it really does sometimes black
has issues in this kind of position it
with h4 h5 put H form that doesn't work
you can take care i guess maybe I have
no idea what's going on you it's
probably good them engine gives zero now
it's just a complete mess it shows that
in the Rue Lopez which is often get has
the reputation of being a strategically
focused opening it can be very very
complicated because of all the pieces
still on the board okay well thanks for
watching